welcome back to the final episode in
this season of the deep mind podcast and
boy have we covered a lot of ground
from protein folding ais to sarcastic
language models sauntering robots
synthetic voices and much more it has
been quite the journey
but we do have one more treat in store
for you a chance to hear from deepmind
ceo and co-founder demis hasabis the
outcome i've always dreamed of is
agi has helped us solve a lot of the big
challenges facing society today be that
health creating a new energy source so
that's what i see as happening is a sort
of amazing flourishing to the next level
of humanity's potential with this very
powerful technology
this was my opportunity to ask demis all
the things that have popped into my head
during the making of the series
well most things we'll see how far i can
push it
as luck would have it the day i sat down
with demis coincided with the opening of
deepmind's sparkling new premises in
london's king's cross
there weren't many people about yet so
it felt like an exclusive preview i feel
like i'm in a
high-end furniture catalogue
let me set the scene for you this new
building is rather beautifully appointed
it's got a double helix staircase
running through the middle
there are fiddle leaf trees in
practically every corner
and there are stylish fluted glass
critter doors between offices
and yes those meeting rooms christened
after great scientists galileo ada
lovelace leonardo they are all still a
[Music]
at
feature
sparkling push the boat out while
sipping on my beverage of choice some
memorabilia outside demise's office
caught my eye a nod to alphago's famous
victory over lisa dole in the game go
there is sitting underneath two
extremely fancy black spotlights
a chessboard in a black frame and if i
go over to it
there's a picture of gary kasparov
the
legendary chess player who was beaten by
deep blue the ibm computer
he signed the chessboard and it says for
the alphago team keep conquering new
heights i mean
just a chessboard designed by kasparov
on the wall perfectly standard
oh awesome oh we're going in
hi
great to see you
after settling down inside demise's
office i started by asking him about
deepmind's long-term vision of building
agi or artificial general intelligence
it's an ambition that has been baked
into deep mind's dna from the very
beginning
i think it's fair to say that there's
some people in the field who don't think
that agi is possible
they sort of say that it's a distraction
from the actual work of building
practical ai systems
what makes you so sure that this is
something that's possible i think it
comes down to the definition of agi so
if we define it as a system that's able
to do a wide variety of cognitive tasks
to a human level that must be possible i
think because the existence proof is the
human brain
and unless you think there's something
non-computable in the brain which so far
there's no evidence for then
it should be possible to mimic those
functions
on effectively a turing machine a
computer and then the second part of
that which is it's a distraction from
building practical systems well i mean
that may be true in the sense of what
you're mostly interested is in the
practical systems agi itself is a big
research goal and a long term one it's
not going to happen anytime soon but our
view is that if you try and shoot for
the stars so to speak then any
technologies that you sort of build on
the way can be broken off in components
and then applied to amazing things and
so we think striving for the long-term
ambitious research goal is the best way
to create technologies that you can
apply right now how will you
recognize agi when you see it will you
know it when you see it
what i imagine is going to happen is
some of these ai systems will start
being able to use language and i mean
they already are but better maybe you'll
start collaborating with them say
scientifically and i think more and more
as you put them to use at different
tasks slowly that portfolio will grow
and then eventually we could end up it's
controlling a fusion power station and
eventually i think one system or one set
of ideas and algorithms will be able to
scale across those tasks and everything
in between and then once that starts
being built out there will be of course
philosophical arguments about is that
covering all the space of what humans
can do and i think in some respects it
will definitely be beyond what humans
are able to do which will be exciting as
long as that's done in the right way and
you know there'll be cognitive
scientists that will look into does it
have all the cognitive capabilities we
think humans have creativity what about
emotion imagination memory and then
there'll be the subjective feeling
that these things are getting smarter
but i think that's partly why this is
the most exciting journey in my opinion
that humans have ever embarked on which
is i'm sure that trying to build agi
with a sort of neuroscience inspiration
is going to tell us a lot about
ourselves and the human mind the way
you're describing it there is though
this big goal in the future that you
steadily approach
i'm wondering whether
in your mind there's also like a day
where this happens like you know how
children dream of lifting the world cup
have you thought about the day when you
walk off
walk away from the office and you're
like it happened today
yeah i'd have dreamed about that for a
very long time i think it would be more
romantic in some sense if that happened
where you you know one day you're coming
in and then this lump of code is just
executing then the next day you come in
and it sort of feels sentient to you be
quite amazing from what we've seen so
far it will probably be more incremental
and then a threshold will be crossed but
i suspect it will start feeling
interesting and strange in this middle
zone as we start approaching that we're
not there yet i don't think none of the
systems that we interact with or built
have that feeling of sentience or
awareness any of those things they're
just kind of programs that execute
albeit they learn but i could imagine
that one day that could happen you know
there's a few things i look out for like
perhaps coming up with a truly original
idea creating something new a new theory
in science that ends up holding maybe
coming up with its own problem that it
wants to solve these kinds of things
would be sort of activities that i'd be
looking for on the way to maybe that big
day if you're a betting man then when do
you think that will be so i think that
the progress so far has been pretty
phenomenal i think that it's coming
relatively soon in the next you know i
wouldn't be super surprised the next
decade or two shane said that he writes
down predictions and his confidence on
them and then checks back to see how
well he did in the past do you do the
same thing i don't do that no i um i'm
not as methodical as shane so and he
hasn't shown me his recent predictions i
don't know where they were secretly
putting them down i have to ask him it's
just a draw in his hand yes exactly
[Music]
like shane legg deepmind's co-founder
and chief scientist who we heard from in
an earlier episode demis believes that
there are certain abilities that humans
have but are missing from current ai
systems
today's learning systems are really good
at learning in messy situations so
dealing with vision or intuition in go
so pattern recognition they're amazing
for that
but we haven't yet got them
satisfactorily back up to be able to use
symbolic knowledge so doing mathematics
or language even we have some of course
language models but they don't have a
deep understanding yet still of concepts
that underlie language and so they can't
generalize or write a novel or make
something new how do you test whether
say a language model has a conceptual
understanding of what it's coming out
with that's a hard question and
something that we're all wrestling with
still so we have our own large language
model just like most teams in these days
and it's fascinating probing it you know
at three in the morning that's one of my
favorite things to do is just have a
have a little chat with the uh
with the ai system
uh sometimes but i'm generally trying to
break it to see exactly this like does
it really understand what you're talking
about
one of the things that suspected they
don't understand properly is
quite basic real world situations that
rely on
maybe experiencing physics or acting in
the world because obviously these are
passive language models right they just
learn from reading the internet so you
can say sort of things like alice threw
the ball to bob ball through back to
alice alice throws it over the wall bob
goes and gets it who's got the ball and
you know obviously in that case it's bob
but it can get quite confused sometimes
it'll say alice or so it'll say
something random so it's those types of
you know almost like a kid would
understand that and it's interesting are
there basic things like that that it
can't get about the real world because
it's all it sort of only knows it from
words but it's a that in itself is a
fascinating philosophical question i
think what we're doing
is philosophy actually in the greatest
tradition of that trying to understand
philosophy of mind philosophy of science
when it's 3am and you're talking to a
language model do you ever ask if it's
an agi yeah
i think i must have done that yes with
varying answers but it has responded yes
at some point yeah it does sometimes
respond yes and you know i'm an
artificial system and it knows what agi
is
to some level i don't think it really
knows anything to be honest that would
be my conclusion it knows some words no
words a clever parent yes exactly
for the moment at least ai systems like
language models show no signs of
understanding the world
but could they ever go beyond this in
future
do you think that consciousness could
emerge as a sort of natural consequence
of a particular architecture or do you
think that it's something that has to be
intentionally created
i'm not sure
i suspect that intelligence and
consciousness are what's called double
dissociable you can have one without the
other both ways my argument for that
would be that if you have a pet dog for
example i think they're quite clearly
have some consciousness you know they
seem to dream they're sort of self-aware
of what they want to do
but they're not you know dogs are smart
but they're not that smart right and so
it's my dog isn't anyway but on the
other hand if you look at intelligent
systems the current ones we built okay
they're quite narrow but they are very
good at say games i could easily imagine
carrying on with building those types of
alpha zero systems and they get more
general more and more powerful but they
just feel like programs so that's one
path and then the other path is that it
turns out consciousness is integral with
intelligence so in least in biological
systems they seem to both increase
together so it suggests that maybe
there's a correlation it could be that
it's causative so
it turns out if you have these general
intelligence systems they automatically
have to have a model of their own
conscious experience personally i don't
see why that's necessary so i think by
building ai and deconstructing it we
might actually be able to triangulate
and pin down what the essence of
consciousness is and then we would have
the decision of do we want to build that
in or not my personal opinion is at
least in the first stages we shouldn't
if we have the choice because i think
that brings in a lot of other complex
ethical issues tell me about some of
those well i mean i think if an ai
system was conscious and you believed it
was then you'd have to consider what
rights it might have and then the other
issue as well is that conscious systems
or beings have generally come with free
will and wanting to set their own goals
and i think um you know there's some
safety questions about that as well and
so i think it would fit into a pattern
that we're much more used to with our
machines around us to view ai as a kind
of tool or
if it's language based the kind of
oracle it's like the world's best
encyclopedia right you ask a question
and it has like you know all research to
hand but not necessarily
an opinion or a goal to do with that
information right its goal would be to
give that information in the most
convenient way possible to the human
interactor wikipedia doesn't have a
theory of mind and maybe it's best to
keep maybe it's best to keep it like
that exactly okay how about a moral
compass then can you impart a moral
compass into ai and should you
i mean i'm not sure i would call it a
moral compass but definitely it's going
to need a value system because whatever
goal you give it you're effectively
incentivizing that ai system to do
something
and so
as that becomes more more general you
can sort of think about that as almost a
value system what do you want it to do
in its set of actions what you do want
to sort of disallow
how should it think about side effects
versus its main goal what's its top
level goal if it's to keep humans happy
which set of humans what does happiness
mean we can definitely need for help
from philosophers and sociologists and
others about defining and psychologists
probably you know defining what a lot of
these terms mean and of course a lot of
them are very tricky
for humans to figure out our collective
goals
what do you see as the best possible
outcome of having agi the outcome i've
always dreamed of or imagined is
agi has helped us solve a lot of the big
challenges facing society today be that
health
cures for diseases like alzheimer's i
would also imagine agi helping with
climate
creating a new energy source that is
renewable and then what would happen
after those kinds of first stage things
is you kind of have this sometimes
people describe it as radical abundance
if we're talking about radical abundance
of i don't know water and food and
energy how does ai help to create that
so it helps to create that by unlocking
key technological breakthroughs let's
take energy for example
we are looking for as a species
renewable cheap ideally free
non-polluting energy
and to me there's at least a couple of
ways of doing that one would be to make
fusion work much better than nuclear
fission it's much safer that's obviously
the way the sun works we're already
working on one of the challenges for
that which is containing the plasma in a
fusion reactor and we already have the
state-of-the-art way of doing that sort
of unbelievably the other way is to make
solar power work much better if we had
solar panels just tiling something you
know half the size of texas that would
be enough to power the whole world's
uses of energy so it's just not
efficient enough right now but if you
had superconductors you know room
temperature superconductor which is
obviously the the holy grail in that
area if that was possible suddenly that
would make that much more viable and i
could imagine ai helping with material
science that's a big combinatorial
problem huge search space all the
different compounds you can combine
together which one's the best
and of course edison sort of did that by
hand when he found tungsten for light
bulbs but imagine doing that at
enormous scale or much harder problems
than a light bulb that's kind of the
sorts of things i'm thinking an ai could
be used for i think you probably know
what i'm going to ask you next because
if that is the fully optimistic utopian
view of the future
it can't all be positive when you're
lying awake at night what are the things
that you worry about well to be honest
with you i do think that is a very
plausible end state the optimistic one i
painted you and of course that's what i
reason i work on ai's because i hoped it
would be like that on the other hand one
of the biggest worries i have is what
humans are going to do with
ai technologies on the way to agi like
most technologies
they could be used for good or bad and i
think that's down to us as a society and
governments to decide which direction
they're going to go in do you think
society is ready for agi
i don't think
yet i think that's part of what this
podcast series is about as well is to
give the general public a more of an
understanding of what agi is what ai is
and what's coming down the road and then
we can start grappling with as a society
and not just the technologists what we
want to be doing with these systems you
said you've got this sort of 20-year
prediction
and then simultaneously where society is
in terms of understanding and grappling
with these ideas
do you think that deep mind has a
responsibility to
hit pause at any point
potentially i always imagine that
as we got closer to the sort of gray
zone that you were talking about earlier
the best thing to do might be to pause
the pushing of the performance of these
systems so that you can analyze down to
my new detail exactly and maybe even
prove things mathematically about the
system so that you know the limits and
otherwise of the systems that you're
building at that point i think all the
world's greatest minds should probably
be thinking about this problem so that
was what i would be advocating to you
know the terence towers of this world
the best mathematicians is actually if
i've even talked to him about this i
know you're working on the riemann
hypothesis or something which is the
best thing in mathematics but actually
this is more pressing i have this sort
of idea of like almost uh avengers
assembled of the scientific world
because that's a bit of like my dream
deterrence tower agree to be one of your
avengers
i don't i didn't quite tell him the full
plan of that
i know that some quite prominent
scientists have spoken in quite serious
terms about this path towards getting
agi i'm thinking about stephen hawking
do you ever have debates with those kind
of people about what the future looks
like yeah i actually talked to stephen
hawking a couple of times i went to see
him in cambridge i was supposed to be a
half an hour meeting but we ended up
talking for hours
he wanted to understand what was going
on at the coalface of ai development and
i explained to him what we were doing
the kinds of things we've discussed
today what we're worried about and he
felt much more reassured that people
were thinking about this in the correct
way
and
at the end he said i wish you the best
of luck but not too much
then he looked at right in my eye and
twinkle in his eye like it was just
amazing that was literally his last
sentence today
best of luck but not too much
that's lovely that was perfect it is
perfect
along the road to adi there have already
been some significant breakthroughs with
particular ai systems or narrow ai as
it's sometimes known
not least the deepmind system known as
alpha fold which we heard about in
episode 1.
alpha fold has been shown to accurately
predict the 3d structures of proteins
with implications for everything from
the discovery of new drugs to pandemic
preparedness
i asked ms how a company known for
getting computers to play games to a
superhuman level was able to achieve
success in some of the biggest
scientific challenges in the space of
just a few short years
the idea was always from the beginning
of deep mind to
prove our general learning ideas
reinforce learning deep learning
combining that on games tackle the most
complex games there are out there so go
and starcraft in terms of computer games
and board games and then the hope was we
could then start tackling real world
problems especially in science which is
my other huge passion and at least my
personal reason for working on ai was to
use ai as the ultimate tool really to
accelerate scientific discovery in
almost any field because if it's a
general tool then it should be
applicable to many many fields of
science and i think alpha fold which is
our program for protein folding is our
first massive example of that and i
think it's woken up the scientific world
to the possibility of what ai could do
what impact do you hope that our fold
will have
i hope alpha fold is the beginning of a
new era in biology where computational
and ai methods are used to help
model all aspects of biological systems
and therefore accelerate our discovery
process in biology so i'm hoping that
it'll have a huge effect on drug
discovery but also fundamental biology
understanding what these proteins do in
your body and i think that if you look
at machine learning it's the perfect
description language for biology in the
same way that maths was the perfect
description language for physics and
many people obviously in the last 50
years have tried to apply mathematics to
biology with some success but i think
it's too complex for mathematicians to
describe in a few equations but i think
it's the perfect regime for machine
learning to spot patterns machine
learning is really good at taking
weak signals messy signals and making
sense of them which is i think the
regime that we're in with biology
how could ai be used for a future
pandemic
so one of the things actually we're
looking for now is the top 20 pathogens
that biologists are identifying could
cause the next pandemic to fold all the
proteins which mean you know it's
feasible involved in all those viruses
so that drug discovery and farmer can
have a head start at figuring out what
drugs or antidotes or antivirals would
they make to combat those if those
viruses ended up mutating slightly and
becoming the next pandemic i think in
the next few years we'll also have
automated drug discovery processes as
well so we won't just be giving the
structure of the protein we might even
be able to propose what sort of compound
might be needed so i think there's a lot
of things ai can potentially do and then
on the other side of things maybe on the
analysis side to track trends and
predict how spreading might happen
given how significant the advances are
for science that are being created by
these ai systems do you think that there
will ever be a day
where an ai wins a nobel prize
i would say that just like any tool it's
the human ingenuity that's gone into it
you know it's sort of like saying who
should we credit spotting jupiter's
moons is it his telescope no i think
it's galileo and of course he also built
the telescope right famously as well as
it was his eye that saw it and then he
wrote it up so i think it's a nice sort
of science fiction story to say well the
ai should win it but at least until we
get to full agi if it's sentient it's
picked the problem itself it's come up
with a hypothesis and then it solved it
that's a little bit different but for
now where it's just a fairly automated
tool effectively i think the credit
should go probably to the humans i don't
know quite like the idea of giving
nobels to inanimate objects like larger
hadron collider can have one exactly
regression
telescope can have one exactly i just
quite like that idea
even before agi has been created it's
clear that ai systems like averfold are
already having a significant impact on
real world problems
but for all their positives there are
also some tricky ethical questions
surrounding the deployment of ai which
we've been exploring throughout this
series things like the impact of ai on
the environment
and the problem of biased ai systems
being used to help make decisions on
things like access to healthcare or
eligibility for parole
what's your view on ai being used in
those situations i just think we have to
be very careful that the hype doesn't
get ahead of itself
there are a lot of people think ai can
just do anything already and actually if
they understood ai properly they'd know
that the technology is not ready and one
big category of those things is very
nuanced human judgment about human
behavior so parole board hearing would
be a good example of that there's no way
ai's ready yet to kind of model the
balance of factors that experience say
parole board member is balancing up
across society how do you quantify those
things mathematically or in data and
then if you add in a further thing which
is how critical that decision is either
way
then all those things combined
mean to me that it's not something that
ai should be used for certainly not to
make the decision at the level ais at
the moment i think it's fine to use it
as an analysis tool to triage like a
medical image but the doctor needs to
make the decision
in our episode on language models we
talk about some of the more concerning
potential uses of them
is there anything that deep mind can do
to really prevent some of those
nefarious purposes of language models
like spreading misinformation
we're doing a bunch of research
ourselves on you know the issues with
language models i think there's a long
way to go like in terms of building
analysis tools to interpret what these
systems are doing and why they're doing
it i think this is a question of
understanding why are they putting this
output out and then how can you
fix those issues like biases fairness
and what's the right way to do that of
course you want truth at the heart of it
but then there are subjective things
where people from different say
political persuasions have a different
view about something what are you going
to say is the truth at that point so
then it sort of impinges on like well
what does society think about that and
then which society are you talking about
and
these are really complex questions and
because of that this is an area i think
that we should be proceeding with
caution in terms of deploying these
systems in products and things
how do you mitigate the impact that ai
is having on the environment is there
just a danger of building larger and
larger and larger energy-hungry systems
and having a negative impact yeah i mean
we have to consider this i think that ai
systems are using a tiny sliver of the
world's energy usage even the big models
compared to
watching videos online all of these
things are using way more computers and
bandwidth second thing is that actually
most of the big data centers now
especially things like google are pretty
much 100 carbon neutral but we should
continue that trend to become fully
green data centers and then of course
you have to look at the benefits of what
you're trying to build so let's say a
healthcare system or something like that
relative to energy usage most ai models
are hugely net positive and then the
final thing is we've proven is that
actually building the ai models can then
be used you know to optimize the energy
systems itself so for example one of the
best applications we've had of our ai
systems is to control the cooling in
data centers and save like 30 of the
energy they use you know that saving is
way more than we've ever used for all of
our ai models put together probably so
it's an important thing to bear in mind
to make sure it doesn't get out of hand
but i think right now i think that
particular worries are sort of slightly
over hyped
while demis and his colleagues at
deepmind are thinking hard about what
could go wrong when ai is deployed in
the real world what really shone through
during our conversation was demus's
faith in the idea that ultimately
building ai and agi will be a net
positive for the whole of society
if you look at the
challenges that confront humanity today
climate sustainability inequality
the natural world all of these things
are in my view getting worse and worse
and there's going to be new ones coming
soon down the line like access to water
and so on which i think are going to be
really major issues in the next 50 years
and if there wasn't something like ai
coming down the road i would be
extremely worried for our ability to
actually solve these problems but i'm
optimistic we are going to solve those
things because i think ai is coming and
i think it will be the best tool that
we've ever created
in some ways it's hard not to be drawn
in by demise's optimism to be enthused
by the tantalizing picture he paints of
the future
and it's becoming clearer that there are
serious benefits to be had as this
technology matures but as research
swells behind that single north star of
agi
it's also evident that this progress
comes with its own serious risks too
there are technical challenges that need
resolving but ethical and social
challenges too that can't be ignored
and much of that can't be resolved by ai
companies alone
they require a broader societal
conversation
one which i hope at least in some small
way is fueled by this podcast
but i'm struck most of all by how far
the field has come in such a short space
of time at the end of the last season we
were talking enthusiastically about ai
playing atari games and go and chess
and now
all of a sudden as these ideas have
found their feet we can reasonably look
forward to ai making a difference in
drug discovery and nuclear fusion and
understanding the genome
and i do wonder what new discoveries
might await when we meet again
[Music]
deepmind the podcast has been a
whistle-down production the series
producer is dan hardoon with production
support from jill ateneku the editor is
david prest sound design is by emma
barnaby and nigel appleton is the sound
engineer
the original music for this series was
specially composed by elainey shaw and
what wonderful music it was
i'm professor hannah fry thank you for
listening
you